hey everybody I am live welcome to the
live stream a lot of stuff to talk about
Jeff sessions will be testifying
tomorrow we are back from not really a
vacation but had a no-show on Friday as
I was traveling down to Ring of Fire
studios in Pensacola Florida learned a
lot about technology studio building
possibilities for the David Pakman show
talked about that on today's bonus show
not going to talk about it here too much
since I did talk about it but a lot to
discuss as far as that trip goes it was
quite a sociological experience to say
the least so I will get into shortly the
Jeff Sessions thing a lot of other
things that I do want to mention if this
is your first live stream a few notes
I'm really live unless you're watching a
replay and if it is not 6:00 p.m.
Eastern Time right now on Monday June
12th then this might be a replay number
two super chat is on people already
using super chat super chat questions
and comments will be read answered if an
answer is appropriate that is the dollar
sign below the text window number three
any new members or new patrons who sign
up or pledge during the stream I will
give you a thank you and shout out and
talk about how great of a person you are
and sing your praises you can find out
more about that at david pakman.com
slash membership and patreon.com slash
david pakman show more on that later
number four there are moderators
checking out what's going on in the chat
they have been deputized based on very
specific criteria and guidelines that
I've established they will block you for
obvious trolling and hate you will be
banned
and I believe that that is not only from
this livestream but from all future live
streams subtle trolling probably will
not get you banned if it is subtle
enough and where the line of subtlety is
well I guess we'll find out it'll be
quite an experience let's talk about
what's going on with jeff sessions jeff
sessions will now be testifying tomorrow
in regards to the trump russia
investigation now this is relevant for a
number of reasons please check out the
link that is in the description ok from
the washington post that is a link
talking about why jeff sessions is
testimony on russia is so important now
i'm going to talk about some of what
that link says i do not deny that jeff
sessions testifying about russia is
important I just don't believe we're
going to get anything of importance out
of Jeff sessions tomorrow he is now so
so let me set the context for you here
last week James Comey testified but
prior to that there was testimony from
NSA director Admiral Mike Rogers
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates acting FBI director Andrew McCabe
and who is the fourth person it's
escaping me in any case that testimony
opened the door to basically saying I'm
not going to answer
not because it's legally questionable
not because the White House has invoked
executive privilege but Dan Coates got
into a back-and-forth with Senator angus
King where he was saying I am NOT going
to speak about that and and angus King
said well why why not has the White
House exerted in executive privilege and
Dan Coates said no it hasn't
and this King asked do you have any
legal basis for not answering this
question and Dan code said no I really
don't I just am NOT going to talk about
conversations I may or may not have
with President Trump or whatever the
case may have been now that that has
happened and it was accepted as
apparently legitimate in some way shape
or form Jeff Sessions is going to show
up tomorrow it's not like Jeff Sessions
has agreed to testify despite what his
boss Donald Trump wants him to do Jeff
Sessions has agreed to testify for
strategic purposes after the testimony
of James Comey and he's going to show up
and if the answers to the questions he's
asked probably by Republicans are
answers that will then be tweeted about
by Trump and parodied by Sean Spicer as
really great for Donald Trump Jeff
Sessions will answer the questions when
the questions are likely from Democrats
and maybe some fair-minded Republicans
questions that by answering would
potentially paint sessions or Trump in a
negative light sessions is going to say
related to an ongoing investigation so
I'm not going to answer i recused myself
from things related to Trump Russia who
believes that so I'm not going to answer
that he will just not answer and you
will get people like angus King who will
say well hold on is there really a solid
legal basis to your non answer here and
there won't be but it is going to work
don't think that Jeff Sessions is going
to choose to show up and all of a sudden
it's going to be a disaster for Donald
Trump what we can hope for is that the
non answers are crafted tactically in
terms of the questions asked primarily
by Democratic senators such that not
saying no by Jeff Sessions will raise
red flags and we saw that with the
testimony last week with Admiral mike
rogers and dni coats etc and hopefully
it'll happen tomorrow now I am going to
get into why it's important to hear from
Jeff Sessions on this before I do that
let me just go through a few Super chats
real quick Getty Germany sent a 2 euro
super chat saying happy cob feffy will a
happy cob feffy to you it is 6
6:00 p.m. the hour of cab fare as they
say repentant gamer sent a $2 Super chat
does Islam have anything to do with
Islam I would say yes
Jacob ball sent a $2 super chat at 6:01
p.m. on June 12th is this live the
answers of course yes we are live right
now and repentant gamer sent a $5 super
chat asking what do I think about reza
aslan being fired from CNN also did you
know he's a scholar no comment on the
scholar part I think the videos have
done speak for themselves
I believe that CNN was completely within
their rights and I understand why they
chose to sever ties with reza aslan it
makes absolute perfect sense to me based
on the things he said on Twitter am i
offended by the insults about donald
trump that reza aslan made on twitter of
course not not that i that that's not an
argument is i'ma find it offensive Trump
is a buffoonish disaster and I've made
many similar comments on my show but I
understand why CNN would choose to sever
ties with Reza Aslan so let's get now to
the article that I've linked to from the
Washington Post in the description to
this live stream by Amber Phillips why
is it important that we hear from Jeff
Sessions number one sessions met with
Russians during the campaign when they
were allegedly helping Donald Trump win
that is one reason why hearing from Jeff
Sessions is a really really important
thing Congress is going to want to know
did Jeff Sessions have more meetings
with the Russians that he didn't
disclose why did he lie about those
meetings we can expect that he would say
he didn't remember the meetings had
taken place
what did Russia want to talk about I
can't assume that Jeff Sessions is going
to tell us but relevant nonetheless
number two from amber Phillips's article
in The Washington Post Jeff Sessions was
James commis boss when James Comey said
Trump was trying to interfere in the FBI
Russia investigation as James Comey
testified last week Jeff Sessions was
asked to leave the room by Donald Trump
when the conversation that
James Comey has described with Trump
took place so it is very relevant to
talk to Jeff Sessions about that dynamic
did Jeff Sessions when that happened
suspect that Donald Trump was trying to
interfere in an investigation would it
have mattered two sessions could he have
done anything given that he had recused
himself from anything related to Russia
as you can see this is a complete and
utter mess number three Jeff Sessions
has technically recused himself from the
Russia investigation but it's possible
that Jeff Sessions violated his own
recusal so this is something that I hope
senators ask about when Jeff Sessions
testifies tomorrow what does a recusal
mean in the mind of Jeff Sessions did
putting his name on the letter
recommending the firing of James Comey
count as a violation of that recusal can
he be trusted not to interfere going
forward these are all questions that
Amber Philips is absolutely spot-on
about when it comes to Jeff Sessions and
his involvement in the Russia
investigation his recusal his lies but
are we going to get any answers from
Jeff Sessions about these things I would
be stunned I would be absolutely stunned
because this is something Jeff Sessions
is planning is opting to do this is an
optional testimony and Jeff Sessions is
not going to say what the hell let me
get myself in a heap of [ __ ] by
volunteering to testify now it could
backfire it could backfire so even
though this was a decision that was made
maybe to try to redirect from the Comey
testimony maybe to try to take attention
away from something that Trump's going
to do at 3:47 a.m. in the morning
tonight we don't know yet we don't know
yet but there is no doubt that it could
backfire as have so many of the things
that Donald Trump has done and I will be
I will be watching with interest no
doubt about
let me say thank you big thank you to
Matthew O'Brien who has just signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
membership is the number one funding
source for the david pakman show you can
sign up for a monthly or yearly
membership if the normal prices are a
bit high for you not to worry we have a
coupon code you can select to use the
coupon code by using by typing in I
voted 17 all one word all lowercase on
the second page of the signup form also
during the live stream Ken Turner has
signed up using that coupon code Nick
Monroe has signed up just in the first
11 minutes of this live stream thanks to
all of you
Kelly Edgar have signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership thank you
you are truly great people you are
supporting alternatives to homogeneous
corporate media and in the wake of the
YouTube advertiser boycott and I hope
you're up to speed on that the New York
Times wrote about the YouTube advertiser
boycott specifically how it's affecting
the David Pakman show YouTube channel
wired wrote about the YouTube advertiser
boycott specifically addressing how it
is impacting the David Pakman show
YouTube channel we have lost sadly I
wish I could tell you it's all
gingersnaps and waterfalls but we have
lost two thirds of our revenue as a
result of the YouTube advertiser boycott
and as a result talking about the
importance of membership has never been
more relevant also on the program
tomorrow I will be addressing a number
of other important issues on the program
tomorrow number number two after talking
about the Jeff Sessions testimony is
that Donald Trump's Muslim majority
country travel ban has failed again in
court the new york times just in the
last couple of hours writing about this
yet again this is the second iteration
of donald trump's attempted Muslim
majority country travel ban a second
federal appeals court
has ruled against the revised version of
Donald Trump's travel ban this came from
the United States Court of Appeals for
the Ninth Circuit in San Francisco and
people who follow this to at all know
that the Ninth Circuit is considered the
most liberal blah blah blah but they
have just added their stamp onto what we
have already seen from multiple multiple
courts saying it's just not going to
happen it just can't be the courts the
decisions arriving at the same basic
conclusion which is that the First
Amendment's prohibition of government
establishment of religion is being
violated and that even if Donald Trump
even if we pretend that Donald Trump
never talked on the campaign trail about
targeting Muslims with the banned it
effectively and disproportionately
impacts Muslims and as a result it's a
violation of the First Amendment plain
and simple how funny is it that the
elected official from the party that
claims to be all about the Constitution
has put two times four put forth two
times a proposal that according to
multiple court rulings violates the
Constitution and not some obscure
amendment from the Constitution but the
First Amendment to the Constitution so
bad news for Trump and what I'm sort of
thinking about is our Trump supporter is
going to keep him accountable hold him
accountable for this because they may
choose to say Trump promised he would do
it and he did it it's not his fault that
evil liberal judges all over the country
in a variety of states have incorrectly
claimed that it violates some bogus
document oh wait a second you have a
constitution the document that we obsess
about and fetishize I think that there
is no doubt that some trumpets will say
he did everything he could
except propose a constitutional bill and
it's the fault of Democrats it's the
fault of activist judges it's
fault of I don't know Barack Obama still
whatever the case may be he is going to
be given a pass by many many trumpets
there is no doubt about it whatsoever so
we'll talk about Jeff Sessions testimony
tomorrow on the show we will talk about
Donald Trump's travel ban failing once
again we will talk about eight
congressional leaders that are opposed
to net neutrality but specifically we're
going to talk about how much money they
received from Internet service providers
like Comcast and Verizon and ISPs and
represent us represent dot us which is
run actually by friend of the show or at
least was I hope he hasn't left I
believe he's still involved here Josh
silver formerly a free press more
recently of represent us and we're going
to talk about congressman Greg Walden
and our old buddy congresswoman Marsha
Blackburn we're going to talk about John
Thune we're going to talk about Roger
wicker and Paul Ryan and cathy McMorris
Rogers and Tom grades and I'm going to
tell you not about the hundreds not
about the thousands not about the tens
of thousands of dollars but about the
hundreds of thousands of dollars that
some of the key voices opposed to net
neutrality some of the money that they
have received from the very companies
that stand to benefit from getting rid
of net neutrality it's the story about
corruption
I mean plain and simple it is a story
about corruption period and we're going
to be talking about it on the program
tomorrow I also am going to talk about
so I I don't know how many people will
be surprised by my view on this megyn
kelly formerly of Fox News months ago
announced she was leaving Fox News and
she was going to get a new program I
think it's a Sunday night show on NBC
News and this is sort of like main NBC
not MSNBC but NBC channel five on my
cable system one of those main Network
channels and the idea was going to be a
investigative hard-hitting she did this
interview with Vladimir Putin which I
thought was quite interesting to be
be honest with you and very interesting
work and she is now teasing and
interviewed that she did with Alex Jones
conspiracy theorist of Infowars Fame and
she is getting slammed absolutely
slammed for that saying many people
saying you are bringing to the
mainstream a guy who thinks 9/11 was an
inside job a guy who I ought to be frank
I don't know exactly what his position
is right now on the Sandy Hook shooting
but at one point he believed some
combination of it was staged with crisis
actors and it was an Obama thing to
create a pretext to take guns which by
the way he never did it cetera et cetera
so there are lots of people saying this
is an embarrassment Alex Jones should be
no platformed now if you're at all
familiar with my show you know that I
don't believe in the concept of no
platforming at its core there are
individuals that I don't believe are
worthy of being given time because we're
not really going to learn anything
interesting right so for example when I
interview the Westboro Baptist Church
that is a notable church up for decades
at this point has been on the forefront
of anti-gay bigotry and I think we've
learned quite a bit about the sources of
extremism and how people become
radicalized and their thought processes
etc etc so you could argue how you don't
give them the platform I've opted in the
past although I don't do it anymore
because it's old news there's there's
nothing more to hear from them to talk
to them because I was interested in
figuring out how did they get to where
they are on the other hand if you come
to me and you say hey interview this
random street preacher who is on the
streets of Cleveland Ohio
I mentioned that only because the last
time I was in Cleveland I walked by a
street preacher that nobody knows or
pays attention to who's also a
homophobic nut I'm not not interviewing
that person because I'm no platforming
them I just think that their ideas are
not notable in the sense that many
people are anti-gay
and that random street preacher has not
really made an impact in any way now as
a result where am I on megyn kelly
interviewing Alex Jones I have no
problem with interviewing a prominent
conspiracy theorist as long as you are
not bringing them on to talk about how
great they are or to provide no
opposition factual opposition to what
they're saying from the preview that
I've seen megyn kelly doesn't do that
she seems to be there in opposition of
what Alex Jones is saying and I don't
believe that saying we're going to no
platform Alex Jones is something that
that is logical or that I would support
that being said there is a case to be
made that NBC News a premier and
flagship program launched with much
fanfare with megyn kelly launched under
the controversy of the problems that she
had with the late Roger Ailes with
regards to sexual harassment and bla bla
bla bla bla and she didn't speak out
soon enough according to some people
about knowing that that it was going on
I think that the platform is too big for
Alex Jones in other words it's not that
I think conspiracy theorists shouldn't
be interviewed or people with vile ideas
shouldn't be exposed so we learn about
what's going on I think Alex Jones isn't
really worthy of being featured so early
on in this new program on NBC News
that's my problem with it and it is not
an issue of no platforming or anything
along those lines so we'll talk about
that tomorrow I'm going to try to get to
Puerto Rico voting once again in favor
of statehood now they still didn't have
major voter turnout I think it was in
low 20s turnout but 90 something percent
of those who did vote in that
referendum type vote in Puerto Rico said
they want to become a 51st state of the
United States now it's probably not
going to happen and we're going to talk
tomorrow about why and I'm also going to
talk about how that would influence the
balance of power in the United States in
the United States if you think about
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico would more than
likely be a blue state but not as blue
as some people think there's some
assumption that oh it's spanish-speaking
people so it would be like an 80% 90%
blue state or something like that
because it's effectively a completely
Latino a territory and would be state
Puerto Rico has elements of conservatism
so we're going to talk about that
tomorrow on the program and I think that
there's actually a lot there and it's
it's it should be it should be an
interesting conversation so we're going
to talk about that let me adjust my mic
volume a couple people saying that I am
difficult to hear let's see here I'm
just going to tweak it a little bit see
if that makes it any better I haven't
changed any settings so I'm surprised
that in trouble hearing me I might have
accidentally just muted myself for a
second there
I'll move the microphone a little bit
closer and see if I can speak up a
little bit okay so all of those stories
tomorrow on the program and a lot of
other interesting and exciting stuff
let's get to some super chats here
Hobbiton has sent a ten British pound
super chat saying let me play devil's
advocate for a second could the Russia
thing be a smokescreen Trump and company
acting suspicious so we focus on a
non-story so we don't focus on his
domestic policy it's a bit nuanced it's
a bit nuanced for for the apparent
intelligence of Donald Trump but there's
no doubt that Donald Trump seems to use
misdirection or redirection when he
wants to move our attention away from
one thing and towards another this is
why I'm making it a point to pay
attention to what Republicans are doing
in the House and Senate to what Donald
Trump is signing just today on the
broadcast program we
talked about this bill that's been
passed by House Republicans that would
do a lot to destroy the provisions of
dodd-frank now hopefully it won't pass
in the Senate or if it does it would
pass with significant revisions but I
think that generally speaking you're not
off that that it's a tactic that is used
is it that broadly what's going on with
the Russia investigation I don't think
so
floppy kid has sent a to Canadian dollar
super chat asking who will play Comey in
the movie you know I believe that
unsaddle II the late great Robin
Williams although typically a comedic
actor could have played James Comey I
know the look isn't exactly right but I
think that he could have done it not
going to happen due to the this sad
death of Robin Williams and I don't know
who would be an alternative good choice
to play James Comey in the movie what
the movie will be I'm not totally sure
yet but I'll think about that a little
more if you're just coming in and if
this is your first David Pakman show
YouTube live stream we are live right
now 624 p.m. Eastern Time on June 12
2017 unless you're watching a replay
we are live I'm chatting with you right
now number two super chat is on those
questions that you heard me reading
those are questions sent by using that
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window and I will get to both questions
and comments there feel free to use that
new members and new patrons will get
live thank-yous and shout outs during
the stream you can become a member at
david pakman.com slash membership you
can become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and please don't troll
obvious trolling and hate will get you
banned and you know there's a bunch of
people by the way that are just putting
Magha
Mogga I don't know
you pronounced it Maga just repeating it
time and again in the chat and I just
blocked a couple of them because that
that's just nonsense we don't we don't
really have time for that here okay
as far as membership goes big big thank
you to Bill Bennett Bill Bennett has
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership bill has opted to save 40% on
his membership by entering the coupon
code
I voted 17 in the coupon code field at I
voted 17 thank you so much bill also big
thank you major thank you I should
actually say to Brian Merritt Brian
Merritt has also signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership I will also
mention that we are continuing to
fundraise to make up for the lost
YouTube revenue on patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow don't be shy every
dollar helps please don't think that
because you might only be able to
contribute a dollar or two that it's not
worth contributing at all over 1,500
people have made contributions as small
as one dollar per month every
contribution contribution is valuable
and I will also do thank-yous and shout
outs to people who do patreon pledges
and you know that the truth is if
everyone who could afford it from our
Youtube subscriber base of now closing
in on 400,000 if everybody who could
afford it did $1 a month we will be
finishing up this funding calamity
quicker than you can say cobb feffy all
right so please check that out and I
will get back to thank yous and shout
outs a little bit later I also want to
tell you that we have a major long-form
piece on political correctness that we
are going to be broadcasting previewing
a premiering I guess is the word I'm
looking for for you
on Monday Monday one week from today
June 19th we are going to premiere a
roughly 15 minute video on political
correctness political correctness is
something that I've talked about quite a
bit political correctness has become a
favorite topic for uh what am I trying
to say here there are those who like to
just talk about social justice warriors
trigger warnings special snowflakes and
political correctness as the singular
problems in American political and
economic culture today and I think that
they're off their rockers at the same
time I am NOT someone who believes in
stifling speech merely because it might
be conceptually quote offensive when
there are worthwhile conversations to be
had now that being said calling a
transgender person by the gender pronoun
that they want to be called is not
really oppressing your ability to speak
freely so we are going to talk about
both sides of this in this long-form
piece next week and I think that you are
going to like it and appreciate our
attempt at telling both sides of the
story because there are there are issues
with overbearing political correctness
however they're not really the ones that
most right-wingers who use political
correctness in the same way that they
say just social justice warrior and
special snowflake so we're going to be
talking about that all right that's
going to be really really good also on
the program tomorrow if I have time for
it
the United States killed more Syrian
civilians than Isis nor Isis and Russia
I guess I would say in March of 2017
which we just got data for there is a
very very interesting blind spot that
exists many times when making
humanitarian arguments for American
military intervention and it often miss
is the reality that our interventions
sometime optional interventions
interventions which feed the
military-industrial complex
interventions which feed the patriotism
marketing complex patriotism national
the faux patriotism nationalism complex
of the American right oftentimes end up
killing or Hort hurting more people in
the humanitarian crisis we claim to be
trying to stop and that is exactly what
the data suggests when it comes to the
situation in Syria
and we're going to talk about that
tomorrow pretty extensively so I hope
that you'll tune into tomorrow's program
let me deal with a couple of Super chats
that have come in a kind a keen I'm not
sure how to pronounce that has sent a-10
Danish Kroners super chat don't know how
much that is offhand I believe a couple
of dollars thank you very much mr.
Toit's Oh or Toit's Oh
tutus oh I'm not sure how to pronounce
that has sent a to British pound super
chat asking whether I think Trump will
chicken out of his fall UK visit it
isn't that the visit he did chicken out
of I believe that it's been pretty
widely reported we did a story on the
show today
but how Donald Trump has told Teresa may
that he is not going to do the visit
that he promised that he accepted
previously to the UK until the situation
will be more welcoming for him and will
not result in protests which it's like
well that's never going to happen unless
you go to countries where protesting is
banned like North Korea or Saudi Arabia
or turkey I mean it Ron I don't know but
what is he talking about and it's funny
because as I said on the program today
there is no bigger triggered special
snowflake to jokingly use the term that
the right uses about some people on the
left there is
uh this is the guy right I mean this is
the guy who seems just constantly
triggered and has to retreat to safe
spaces he did it in Israel he did it in
so many places and it is really really
bizarre okay there is I think we're
caught up on the super chats I want to
mention one thing I saw in the chat
somebody posted oh I see what's going on
a kind' meant to send this question with
the super chat but it didn't go through
uh the treble is horrible in your studio
videos but a lot better in your live
streams like this one please fix it I
have not heard that before and I have
not experienced that I mean I listen to
the studio videos all the time and I've
not noticed that the treble is an issue
I don't know if you're saying that the
high end is a tinny or something like I
really don't know but we've not received
one other comment about it
and I don't know what might be causing
it on your system but but I don't know
I'll look into it tomorrow but it's not
something that that I've heard is an
issue but we will look into it
the technical team will take a look and
we will see what we can figure out I
hope in the next couple of days to be
able to talk about the situation going
on at Breitbart there's a new report out
which alleges in the Washington Post
that Breitbart
which is the propaganda news outlet of
close Trump advisor Steven Bannon has
lost 90% of its advertisers in two
months the number of advertisers on
alt-right breitbart.com has dropped 90%
in recent months from 242 in March to 26
in May according to data from media
radar a New York firm that tracks online
advertising among those that continue to
adverse advertise include a gentlemen's
club in Northern Virginia a Golf Resort
near the coast of Spain and the
conservative foundation Judicial Watch
the Foundation's president tom Fitton
said in an interview liberal activists
want to destroy
Bart but we won't be cowed we advertised
widely on the Internet and we're proud
of the relationship and the partnerships
that we have this is absolutely
fantastic
Breitbart has had this issue where
there's many advertisers that are not
buying ads on individual websites right
they go to an ad network and they say we
want to buy five million impressions a
week or whatever the case may be and we
want to be on news and politics sites
and then their ad through the agency
starts to appear on different websites a
lot of these companies that
inadvertently we're advertising on
breitbart.com were targeted by social
media shame campaigns with screenshots
saying here's your ad next to an article
about how you know the alt-right is
great or whatever the case may be and
that has caused many advertisers
according to this 90% of Breitbart
advertisers to pull their ads from
Breitbart there are some that are
advertising directly with Breitbart but
many of them are going through ad
networks and the ad networks have the
ability to just say this advertiser does
not want to appear on Breitbart and that
is exactly what it seems like is
happening now I want to be super clear
with you some people have written me and
said David how can you support these
targeted boycotts of Breitbart
when your channel is suffering at the
hands of the YouTube advertiser boycott
aren't you supporting what is actually
causing you a problem and the answer is
as you can probably guess no these are
totally different things okay if a
specific advertiser went to YouTube and
said we don't want to advertise on the
David Pakman show because we are getting
blowback about his politics that would
be analogous to what's going on on
Breitbart what happened with the YouTube
advertiser boycott is that as a result
of some of frenetic and panicked
articles including one in The Wall
Street Journal
advertisers threatened to back out total
from advertising on YouTube as a
platform because the articles alleged
YouTube couldn't control when ads showed
up on racist or hateful content of
course that's not true if anything the
opposite is true
YouTube's algorithm is already too
strict and what happened when YouTube
flipped this new advertising algorithm
is that not only did the few targets of
these companies lose ads a whole bunch
of other channels like mine also lost
initially 99% of our revenue and
eventually now we've settled at a loss
of about two-thirds of our revenue so
these situations are not analogous and
so I completely support the public media
shame campaigns for advertisers who are
advertising on specific channels or
websites that is not how we were hurt we
are not the hateful and offensive
content and you know what if somebody
really does if an advertiser really does
disagree with my politics so much that
they don't want to advertise with me I
don't want them advertising with me and
and if anything we are we were sort of
seeing the opposite which is because we
don't do not FCC say FCC unsafe content
we actually are supposed to potentially
have many major advertisers on our
channel who are not playing games with
the politics they advertise on left-wing
and right-wing channels they say we're
just trying to appeal to the demographic
that watches the David Pakman show
YouTube channel so a lot of this is
outlined in the there's been a couple
major articles written about our YouTube
channel one was in Wired magazine and
that's a really great article called
want a better web here's an idea pay for
it by Devi Alba very very good and then
the blockbuster article that was written
about what's going on with our YouTube
channel was in the New York Times by
Amanda Hess who did a really really
great job with this it's called how
YouTube's
shifting algorithms hurt independent
media and that's why we have launched a
patreon fundraiser which is really
important and I'm asking for your
support there even
at the rate of $1 a month even $1 a
month really helps us to make up the
money that we've unfortunately lost 2/3
of because of the YouTube advertiser
boycott and also membership membership
is the number one funding source for our
YouTube channel and we we've been
depending on membership support for a
very very long time it is more important
now than it has ever been and you can
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership we have a coupon code
available for you that coupon code is I
voted 17 and I want to send a big thank
you to s Freeman who has just signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
thank you thank you thank you so very
much for signing up I also want to say
thank you to Steve Copeland Steve
Copeland has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership noah rize's
know what Riza's has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and also
Charles Jewell Charles Jewell has signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
every single membership gets you instant
access to the bonus show ok every day
we've got our broadcast show which is an
hour we do an additional show every day
just for our paid subscribers and I
would love it if you participated you
also get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show every single day and
that is a really really great thing so I
appreciate everybody who's been signing
up record numbers in April solid numbers
in May and we are trying to keep the
momentum going let's jump back into the
Super chats screwdriver has sent a $5
super chat asking David what do you
think of Nevada's current state proposal
to let people buy into the state
Medicaid program regardless of of income
or health status very good question I
generally am in favor of that type of
program
I have not read yet the specifics of
Nevada's program but I will look into it
and get back to you
Jordan Gerlich has sent a $2.00 super
chat saying who if anyone do you hope
runs against Trump in 2020 I've
specifically not been talking about that
because there is so much going on right
now and so much that is important for
progressives to focus on including a
platform for 2018 opposing Trump is fine
but there needs to be something done in
terms of uniting progressives around
issues because the I'm not the other guy
thing did not work very well into in
2004 for John Kerry against George W
Bush it did not even really work well
for Republicans during the Republican
primary in 2016 the hey we're all not
Trump right but what's your message and
none of their messages really broke
through so Jordan really appreciate the
super chat however I think it is too
early to start talking about that
Nicolas Benny has sent a $5 super chat
did you see the alt-right react to the
new Wolfenstein game no I haven't seen
that let's see what's going on with that
I'm going to google that article on Vice
from 10 hours ago the alt-right thinks
Wolfenstein Wolfenstein the new Colossus
is racist to white people
oh geez here we go some people on the
internet don't like it it's not because
of the game trivializing World War 2 or
celebrating violence it's because it's
politically correct and degrades Nazis
and is anti white it has links to 4chan
Wow well listen I've not seen the game
but it's unfair to Nazis is a criticism
according to vice motherboard that is
wild that that is truly truly wild I had
not seen that but that is endlessly
fascinating I actually used to play
Wolfenstein the old old versions I used
to be into
wolfenstein I liked doom
XCOM both UFO defense and the sequel
terror from the deep were games that I
really liked a lot of those games I was
into don't really play too many games
anymore
yeah portal 2 was good that might have
been the last game that I bought I'd
like to play the newest Grand Theft Auto
but my computer can't handle it my
desktop computer is several years old
and I am waiting to get the latest Grand
Theft Auto now I know it's violent and
all this stuff the gameplay is just so
fun and it's one of the one of the types
of games I really really enjoy playing
but no I haven't seen Nicolas Benny I
haven't seen Nick the alt-right reaction
beyond just that article that I took a
look at and it is endlessly fascinating
and I plan to check out the game now
because it is it is very very
interesting alright short stream today
thanks to everybody who joined me please
please make those patreon donations
don't forget to sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership we've got a
whole whole new show for you tomorrow
members get the entire thing commercial
free on audio and video sign up it is
the number one funding source for our
program distributed every day because of
your support to two hundred radio and TV
stations